willkommen zum ersten block mit tag der
richtig geblockt wird und nicht nur
aufgeräumt wird ich lade gerade mein
video hoch und wir sind auf dem sprung
denn am ersten dezember wollte ich
unbedingt das weihnachtliches machen und
wir schauen uns heute den nussknacker
das ballettstück also ich war noch nie
im ballett du auch nicht mehr hier ist
auf jeden fall den der adventskalender
den ich für timo gemacht habe und hier
ist meine und ich habe das erste türchen
noch nicht auch immer was für einen
adventskalender hat eine frau die schon
drei millionen verschiedene aufgemacht
hat natürlich einen selbst gebastelten
und ideen aber was ist das bewusstein
tagen das was für jeden jeden tag ein
kärtchen wenn dein boyfriend weiß was
für eine so spacken du bist gut gemacht
ist das bewusste einfachen danach jetzt
sind wir auf jeden fall nicht achtsam
mein outfit of the day
ich bin für die pretty das kleid habe
ich gerade geschenkt gekriegt deswegen
ist es so aus als ob ich so in
frankreich gleich auf der straße tanzen
könnte münchen los
wir müssen jetzt unbedingt los um 17 uhr
beginnt die vorstellung jetzt ist nur
noch 30 wo ich mich ein bisschen
verkleidet
diese französische so geht es heute hier
die leute
zu verlassen
doch ganz so stark und so ist sie doch
immer besser ich hasse es wenn man so
spät raus fährt richtig nervös und
gestresst bin und das video hat am
anfang
man bloggt es heute so entschied starten
[Musik]
ich habe noch nicht mal mehr fünf
minuten oder
[Musik]
weil er ein gespür für team und ich sind
wirklich rein gerannt haben die tickets
bekommen und sind sofort auf den platz
und dann ging es auch schon los
es klingt wie so eine warteschleife
wir sind gleich anfangen
[Musik]
das kann auch so bitte warten sie ein
nächste freie mitarbeiter ist für sie
gleich zur stelle
[Musik]
also ihr kulturbanausen wenn ihr den
nussknacker nicht kennt dann googelt
einfach mal die geschichte und können
wir uns mal darauf einigen dass die
protagonistin in dem weißen kleid
einfach aussieht wieso und instagram
model famous influenza
[Musik]
und dann dachte ich so jeder gruppentanz
sondern während der aufnahme aufgefallen
dass sie einfach regen gefallen ist aber
gut gerettet
gut gerettet dem gebe ich so 8 von 10.5
ja also ist ein bisschen la marché ich
habe es eigentlich ganz cool das mal so
zu sehen wie die tanzen und so also kann
ich auf jeden fall mal empfehlen
mein favourit war wirklich mitternacht
zwölf glockenschläge gemacht und alle
standen dann habe auch diese zwölf
klassen schön so war dies nur ich
nähmaschine als durch und als wir
dachten der staubsauger geht los
es war ganz ganz früh hier dann hat man
so nicht
das geht doch nicht zur musik und dann
meinte sie das klingt diese
schneemaschinen nicht funktioniert und
von oben dass schnee gefallen aber ich
bin halt superschlau und wir dachten zum
abschluss gehen wir jetzt noch auf dem
gendarmenmarkt weihnachtsmarkt und
ungewollt noch plätze zu selten
willkommen
ich habe mir sollte noch hast du ganz
ehrlich das duale lust auf klettern
zimmer nationalen münchen wieder voll
wir sind gerade an seiner galerie
vorbeigelaufen und wie cool sie bitte
dieses bild aus ach so wir mussten noch
zu einer bank um bargeld zu holen
es sind bestimmte 5000 euro das ist auch
voll cool
das ist aber auch ganz cool aus wie
küche neviges küchen bild hat das echt
jemand gefragt
ja ich bin auch eine kleine künstlerin
bald hängig in irgendwelchen galerien
das sage ich euch und jetzt holen wir
erstmal cash money
[Musik]
ach so timo ist 195 groß ich habe gerade
ganz kurz aufgeklärt dass du 195 groß
bist ich will damit nur sagen also ich
bin nicht wirklich klein ich bin 41 groß
aber teams 195 riesig mit einem klar
oh mein gott es riecht so groß ist jetzt
eigentlich unangenehm dass ich mit der
kamera in der hand herumlaufen
der gendarmenmarkt weihnachtsmarkt ist
wirklich der schönste weihnachtsmarkt
von allen finde ich
[Musik]
der mini mal was los hier ja erst wenn
mehr da sind also nicht wir die einzigen
die auf die idee kommen hierher zu
kommen sind wir fasziniert an
ich weiß nicht warum ich meine hier
haben wir getan fischerweg massen zu
greifen wieder kraft also ich trinke
weißen will wein steht glaube ich
einfach so auf riesen pannen und sogar
zweifel herzen so leitete viele nudeln
machen diese riesigen pfannen und wird
einfach geil was für eine schöne tasse
ist die herrlich valley in berlin als
haben wir aus berlin werden
in mainz war da für uns immer ein sturz
doppelt hält besser für die kaufen
die austausch
wenn sie und ihre familie einen ort zum
nicht entspannen suchen dann besuchen
sie den gendarmenmarkt weihnachtsmarkt
sie sind wir zu hause muss mir
abgewöhnen die bildschirm da oben hin zu
gucken sondern darunter
wir waren jetzt auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
dann waren wir sogar noch was essen in
einem restaurant was so ein bisschen
schicker war und dann ist mir
aufgefallen dass meine fingernägel total
schmutzig also nicht schmutzig aber ich
habe mich nicht unwohl gefühlt in dem
restaurant aber als ich meine
fingernägel gesehen habe dachte ich so
ich gehöre gehört hier einfach nicht hin
also aber mit dunkelheit kommt die
kamera überhaupt nicht zurecht das muss
man schon sagen dass sie richtig aus so
jetzt können wir unser adventskalender
aufmachen
willkommen zu meinem adventskalender
unboxing video und heute machen wir das
erste türchen von unserem ikea
adventskalender auf ruby ich gleich
wieder den modus kommen wenn ich mich
hinsetze natürlich die nummer eins was
könnte wohl ein türchen nummer eins drin
sein
es ist schokolade drin ist mit einer
creme gefüllt bitte achtet nicht auf
meine fingernägel dieses jahren so
richtig rein geschissen mit dem ikea
adventskalender weil und gestand dass es
dieses jahr sind die gewinnchancen viel
kleiner als letztes jahr
ich habe sogar letztes jahr in einem
adventskalender glaube ich 100 euro
gutschein drin gehabt diese erste block
tag ist irgendwie schuss hält
es war so ein chaos das nussknacker
ballett und schneiden
das wird so schwer sein einfach jeden
tag ein video zu lernen aber ich bin
unbedingt schaffen dieses jahr war ich
eigentlich noch nie geschafft habe und
mir wieder jedes jahr vornehmes zu tun
aber wer weiß dieses jahr habe ich ja
ein freund
wir brauchen wir nicht glückwunsch zu
geben weil ich jetzt ein freund habe
weil das schon ziemlich lange her seit
also ich hab schon ziemlich lang ein
freund aber jetzt nach so langer zeit
habe ich irgendwann gedacht das ist halt
super nervig ist immer ein thema über
rauszuhalten und wenn ich eine story
mache und dem hintergrund hustet oder so
oder ich mache eine story und dann
antworten die meisten wenn ich im
wohnzimmer sitzt und irgendwie anfangen
mein handy zu reden antwortet er dann
aus seinem zimmer ja was sagst du ich
kann ihn nicht verstehen
und dann sage ich so nicht machen die
story und und da sieht viel zu gut aus
um nicht mit noch anzugeben
und sind wir mal ehrlich das läuft doch
gut auf youtube ich konnte bei diesen
christbaumkugeln einfach nicht nein
sagen
dies ist eine auster ich liebe aus
sondern ich weiß nicht mal warum ich aus
dann plötzlich so liebe oder wie ihr
sagen würde eine vagina ich mir so ein
ausleihen bild gemalt und alle sagen
apropos geht und mein gott ist hab ich
euch noch gar nicht da habt ihr jetzt ja
geschrieben wer hat es gemalt
wer hat das gemacht das hat nicht gemalt
ich hätte da noch nicht unterschrieben
aber das habe ich einfach so aus meinem
kopf gemalt ich fand es ganz hübsch aber
dann habt ihr geschrieben oh ha woher
ist also dann dachte ich so gras die
leute sorgen so heftiges bild und der
ich zeig euch nochmal den anwender
das ist eigentlich so ein ikea regal ne
so zwei aufeinander gestapelt das steht
hier für unsere ganze technik für die
ganzen kameras oder paar wie schmeckt's
kochbücher die ihr euch übrigens zu
weihnachten auf jeden fall solltet und
dann habe ich mit rachid ape auf jede
zahl auf jedes papier so eine zahl
geschrieben oder geklebt und auf der
rückseite klebt dann das geschenk quasi
und ja ich bin richtig stolz auf diese
idee gewesen
es ist ganz schön ganz schön vorbildlich
dass wir uns beide eine adventskalender
geschenkt haben und ich würde jetzt so
gerne sagen dass das unabsichtlich war
aber ich habe immer gesagt dass ich in
labenz kalender haben will ich ihm auch
ein bastel und meistens ist es so wenn
ich irgendwas schönes mache für den also
für ihn für meinen freund ist so
unangenehm oder ungewohnt das zu sagen
also wenn ich meinen freunden was
schönes machen möchte dann hat er
meistens danach ein schlechtes gewissen
weil er halt nicht so an so etwas denkt
und deswegen hab ich gesagt hey ich
bastel dir dieses jahr ein
adventskalender
wenn du dich nicht schlecht fühlen
willst was will mir auch rein und dann
haben uns weiterhin gebastelt und jetzt
sind wir
das youtube xl zwei herren und 19
durango und baby wer die können nur
babys zusammen machen wir machen uns
adventskalender das ist viel kraft okay
es ist zu spät ich gehe jetzt ins bett
ich muss morgen früh aufstehen die sind
blogs schneiden und dann quasi mein tag
starten und ja das wird jetzt mein leben
seien für die nächsten 24 tage ich bin
gespannt ich habe viele sachen geplant
ich war nach köln
und vielleicht noch mal nach buxtehude
oben an der süd oben zum mehmet ich
wünsche euch einen schönen tag oder
einen schönen abend oder einen schönen
morgen je nachdem wann jetzt schaut und
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder bleibt
dran also morgen dann gute nacht